honestly could not tell you but it was
just like even
even like i just thought christian
dating was so weird
i thought because like there is one
everyone's so involved by the way i
didn't meet my wife for a christian
dating cyborg
i'm sorry i'm sorry there's exceptions
but i think the majority it's weird like
that one i would agree with you because
because one of them like
one they all need to be involved like
why does everyone like i would see these
like people like they would want to talk
to the church leaders about who they
were interested in yeah and they're like
why
why do you need to involve yeah but the
whole point is and they make it they
make it so slow they like pray like yeah
but then at the same time when you're
considering a relationship it's
something that you have to count the
cost it's not something oh i just met
some nice guy that looks nice and we
want to get married surely you should
have the wisdom of elders to sort of vet
things for you because when you're in
that infant's influctuation stage
you can miss red flags
you don't look at the intention behind
it so if i see if i was single and i saw
a girl and i think she's nice she's this
she's that someone could say but she's
got kids out with two different baby
mamas
and the guy said to me are you sure you
want to do that and that made me pause a
bit yeah that's the whole point of
something having that council that's
actually interesting because i found
that like the church is very forgiving
for women
like a lot like they'll kind of think a
lot of times they'll encourage the men
to like date a girl that has been ran
through or like has kids with other like
yeah i think what happens is i think
what should happen there should be
accounting of the course so
for example let's say
for the sake of this conversation adam
likes becky okay he has like i said two
kids from two separate dads right one of
the church elders the pastor would say i
know you're interested right could you
handle having a teenage stepdaughter
okay step son and could you handle the
dynamics with their biological father
what happens is if you want to install
discipline
as if the teenage daughter says to you
you're not my dad
and that could really bring that i think
so far there's accounting of the cost
and if he's happy to deal with it then
yeah don't get me wrong i like i agree
with you but like okay i went oh my god
i went to catholic school and they would
have chastity speakers come in okay okay
have you heard of christina and jason
everett
no i've probably seen that before
without her so basically like
and i tell this story all the time
because they they would come in right
and the girl would basically say she
would say like oh like in high school
like
she would make i was lost i lost myself
i emphasize with her like at a young age
you're given a lot of attention she was
very attractive like okay okay and um
but
then like i found god and i like got my
husband right and i'm like and i
remember thinking because i just think
differently i'm like
so you're telling me you got ran through
and you still found your husband
like
is that how we do it yeah i think
nowadays
sometimes with
american
is the hollywood sort of rags to riches
right i went from i was this yeah and a
happy ending in reality most of the time
life's not like that no yeah and i think
that's why i would agree with you on
that saying that story gives the
impression that oh so far i come to god
god will give me a husband and yeah and
i think and sometimes we have to
remember it's not always going to be a
happy ending sometimes and remember
marriage is not a right and so what we
have to tell some of our brothers and
sisters in the church it's not all right
jesus wasn't married you know and also
the apostles and because yeah they're
taking away the consequence and she gets
now she gets to make money off of this
story
i'm like that sounds great
this is the blueprint go ahead what it
is yeah this is this is another thing
yeah it's like before marriage and stuff
like that right like you know yo yo if a
girl or any female is out prowling up
for a husband right now before it was
more or less it's like
like you like you said before the
podcast started but it was like a range
marriage or something like that nowadays
it's like oh i'm going to go to the club
i'm going to shoot my ass yeah stuff
like that yeah but this is and this is
this is the this is the this is the like
really really like [ __ ] up part right
like
if i'm going to a club and this has
happened like more times than i can
count right did you as like as a guy
right you go out look your voice calls
you and you're like let's go out and you
go out and you have a good time and you
obviously you go to the club obviously
you're expecting to you know meet a lady
or whatever you know whatever now when
the ladies go out they have a girls
night they're like oh blah blah blah
and when you are in the club in a time
like you find it and whatever and you
meet at the girl and stuff like that and
it's like you talk you talk you talk
and then obviously like you know the
whole controversial thing like the ugly
friend always steps in like oh
pushes her to the side but it's just
like it's so much harder now to be like
because if you don't know the person so
for example if i'm going out with just
the guys
and you let's say you locate a group of
girls and you're trying to let's let's
let's try and talk to them and stuff
like that if the girl group or any of
the girls in that group don't doesn't
know you
or hasn't met you before or doesn't know
a friend that you know
it's always going to be a no
and that's that's without fail
no you say that you know you say uh no
no because like honestly
really unless what go go ahead unless
you're very hot okay no but that's not
that's like the only exception
i don't really go out like that but like
i don't know i think
sometimes i don't know i i went to a
pickup event you know what i picked up
it's not a real event no no like a
pickup art so it was like um i i'm i'm
nosy right so i went i went
i found out like pick up artist you know
what that is okay you know you know okay
okay so i went to this like pickup
artist event in ut or in um
vegas where basically all these guys
would pay like five grand i swear to god
i was like you want to make money
learning yeah you know it's actually
it's yeah yeah
yeah yeah
last vegas like it's expensive oh my god
five grand and it was like 10-ish of
them and like basically what they would
do is they they have like five like
three to five-ish instructors you pay
for your own hotel too so there's like
no cost which you just pay the
instructors now five times that's 50
grand three days no do this man right
this is i was like
yeah i had me thinking i'm like can i
teach me how to get one
anyways though so um but i would see
them like approach girls all night like
that's what they would do they would go
to the clubs and like approach girls all
night and like i saw the instructors
take home like three girls in three days
so that's why i say i think it depends
no but you're no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no but that but
that's the thing this is where the
difference comes in right
you're talking
like las vegas nevada right yeah yeah
i'm talking like in uk
you go out to the club look if you're
going out to like a side hustle club one
people but they they they have these
events
right it runs on the outskirts right
right that's what i've known right the
most popular clubs in in like shoreditch
as well as like studio uh 333
mother or something like that um we have
the bull pit and stuff like that these
are like the most popular high-end clubs
don't charge more to korea
yeah but even then so like you have like
some high-end ladies that go in there
you dress up like they look good they
look dressed for the night you know what
i mean
and you as a guy
mentally you're like look i'm i i've
located the person that i want to talk
to yeah approach them yeah and like
girls like this is this is like the
trigger that like crushes every man you
have the courage after the whole night
no matter how much you have to drink
coffee yeah drink bring builds
confidence and yeah that's a god given
you walk up to that girl and you you
know
drop a line on her like whatever it may
be like hi hello or drop like a cheesy
right
the girl literally in that split moment
in a second mentally they're like
i can either crush this guy or i can
like entertain it for a little bit but
this is where the thing comes in because
you the girls that entertain it
potentially could just be like nah i'm
not gonna have sex with you right
but i would ex graciously accept that
all the free drinks that you're buying
me whereas if you just like i wouldn't
personally out with my travel you crush
my dreams of ever talking to you because
it takes me like a pretty person the
time yeah just my time but like the
girls that entertain it expecting like a
whole drink out of you but will never
have sex with you those are the girls i
was like like yo like
you can be born again you can be
whatever like i would i would not [ __ ]
well
i suppose she could give it to her she's
she is being
uh wise as a serpent well yeah
you've never you've never seen the tic
tacs where it's like after i get my
drink and it's the running
but
actually no recently no the truth be
told recently there was a there was a
tick tock that i've seen where the
basically so the dictator goes like this
it goes
and the guy comes up to a girl and he
goes oh can i get you a drink he goes no
it's bad for my legs
why do they swell no they spread
that was the most like most recent one
and that got me thinking i was like
that's not flipping through no matter
what in what universe you live in that's
not really true it used to be like that
but it's not like that anymore because
the girl will you can they will
entertain you as much as she wants to
with no intention of having sex well
that's the one thing i learned from the
pickup event
this was so fun i had a great time i was
i felt like a dude because i was like
get her get her go go
no it was free because i i had the no i
mean i had the guy on my chair so i had
a boyfriend then so i had the guy on my
channel i just thought to make good
content like a girl going to a pickup
event
i had um it wasn't worth it i had to
blur so many faces it took too long too
long but but um i was like they had to
approach so many girls just to get like
laid basically and this was even the
instructors who were like in my opinion
like they're very very good look